also die Politik der Ampel fürrt zu
massiven Frust Wut Verunsicherung das
beste Mittel um die AFD kleiner zu
kriegen ist eine andere eine bessere
Politik und vor allem auch eine
Regierung die dann gemeinsam das wäre
auch schon mal Anfang gemeinsam da steht
und die Dinge durchträgt man kann Unmut
nicht verbieten also er wird ja nicht
durch Verbot wird ja nicht die Zahl der
unzufriedenen kleiner die wird nur
kleiner durch eine andere Politik glaube
umso länger wir dar drüber reden desto
mehr entsteht halt ein Eindruck die
wollen ihre Politik nicht verändern die
wollen sich auch gar nicht mehr bemühen
und die wollen am Ende das was unliebsam
ist verbieten ich weiß ja schon ich an
schau wie die Wahlplakate in Sachsen
sind dann steht da drauf die letzten
freien Wahlen oder sowas das wird diesen
Eindruck noch befördern man würde hier
versuchen den Debatten auszuweichen der
Politik und deswegen würde ich ein
Verbot natürlich nie ausschließen weil
es ist ja immer die Frage wie die AFD
sich weiterentwickelt was da passiert
aber jetzt eine Wochen und monateange
Debatte über diese Frage die nützt am
Ende nur einem Laden und das ist die
AFD